you are all awesome thank you so much
everybody who came to visit me at Comic
Con I just got back and I had the best
time of my life literally I never even
got a break from the amount of people
that came up and said hi to me and
hearing your stories about how my videos
have helped you through tough times and
helped you through depression and and
made your lives just a little bit better
was such an inspiration for me I even
mentioned it in the most recent video of
off but it was just such an honor to get
all these people in one place and be
able to interact one on one with my fans
and not many people know but I made a
promise to myself the first time I went
to comic-con I had about 2,000
subscribers and four people still came
up to me and just if you think about it
you know about that proportionally the
amount of people in the world and how
many people could have been there at one
point still four people came up to me
and said hi that was the most meaningful
thing I had ever seen
I never even expected anyone to come up
and say hi to me with that number and
yet when I came back I made a promise to
myself to dedicate this channel and what
it does to making people's lives better
and we've done so much in that regard
and I am so proud of how far we've come
I want you guys to see there'll be links
up here to an old video of mine very old
video you'll see a very awkward person
who's not comfortable in front of the
camera not that uncomfortable anyway but
you will see me back when I first came
back from comic-con and I made this
promise to myself and looking back
myself on this I've watched this
recently it's just odd to see but I'm so
proud of where we've come and or how far
we've come and where you guys have been
supporting me throughout this entire
time so just thank you so much and watch
that in my 10,000 subscriber video
because we get so many subscribers a day
now just inundated with new people and
I'm so glad that you guys have chosen to
subscribe to me and support my videos
and I want you guys to know who I am
because I'm not just a guy that plays
video games you know this channel has
never been about the games that I play
but more about the entertainment that we
have together in the community that we
build and I harp on that a lot but it
means everything to be you know you guys
have more power than you know especially
you're just one person because meeting
you guys on an individual
level is something that I lose touch
with when I'm behind a computer in my
home alone and I don't have anyone here
that are like regular supporters and yet
all these people came up to me that knew
so much about me and yet I didn't know
anything about them and when I left
comic-con it was weird because I was
kind of sad
because I felt like I had left a lot of
my friends behind these new people that
came up and met me and we're just the
coolest people I could have met and so
many interesting stories about how I'd
help them out
and I tried to give everyone time
possible but my knees and legs are shot
from standing for four days straight but
you guys are just amazing and I I owe
you guys everything to do with my
channel I came from a really shitty part
of my life to where I am today I was
just in the worst spot and a lot of
people know about it because of my draw
my life and I may have tried to make
that a bit more you know engaging and
entertaining but the reality was it I
hadn't liked I was in such a low point
and I used my channel to try to make my
life better and you guys have done that
so many ways I would be nowhere near
this level of goodness 'no stem today
and just being here in LA and may able
to make videos for you guys it's just
the greatest gift that you guys could
give me and when i meet you guys one on
one and i would love to meet every
single one of you but with 2.8 and yes
we across 2.8 million subscribers and
that's amazing but just with that many
people i know i'll never be able to and
that's kind of sad but at the same time
i want you guys to always know that one
person can still make all the difference
in the world i don't really care about
how many people we have
in the community but I do care that
we're always pointed in the right
direction so thank you guys for
believing in me thank you guys for being
there for me and just know that I'm
always going to dedicate myself to
making this a better place I'm always
going to have subscriber or not
subscriber but charity livestreams every
month from now on but either way okay
so all that sappy stuff aside I'm sorry
I get so wordy when it comes to these
things but I wanted to show off because
a lot of fans came up to me and they
gave me cool stuff to see so anyway
there's been so many of these tiny box
Tim things that people have gotten in
like they're so adorable because they're
just so happy and I started signing
signatures with tiny box tin on them and
I'm just so happy because this is so
cute there's another one you yeah oh
it's a Worf - tidy box - oh it's so cute
and there's gonna be pleasures of these
guys for real in a few months here
they're gonna come up for another
charity livestream where you can buy
these for charity it's gonna be awesome
anyway there's more stuff look at this
and it's got mark a mesh on the inside
so that whenever I wear it I can think
about us together mmm and also I got
this shirt someone gave this to me I am
so I'm gonna wear right now everybody
I've hurt your eyes yeah so naked or not
you guys didn't see nothing did you
light and fast Wow but it's home with
home is where the pants are this is my
favorite this is awesome it's my motto I
live by and also I was selling these
shirts while in convention sorry you
guys can't get these anywhere else that
I'm selling exclusive t-shirts at the
convention so thank you everyone who
bought one there and if I gave away free
ones here on license
I'm mmm caricature fan art look at this
little no band stall look how cute it is
he's even got little glasses on the top
they're adorable I need to get underwear
like this that sounds weird by itself
but I need to get underwear like this
with the little hearts on Vegeta what
some scattered say about a power level
this joke is so old swag they said that
this was a baton but I think it's a guns
of Icarus wand holy crap this is awesome
it's a 50 Cal bullet that is on another
bullet I think it's what you fire from a
bow
and then as it fires it then shoots this
and empiricism and then shoots this bull
at the end so it gets like triple
killing action with a bow or maybe I'm
just an idiot
super middle finger defense as a fine
art manner mannered man haha swag my
little biscuit Oh anyway that's just a
little taste of what you guys gave me
while I was at comic-con I cannot wait
for next year's comic-con in whatever
event I go to I haven't been able to go
to as many conventions as I would like
this year I have been incredibly busy
but just thank you guys for being the
most amazing fans in the world I can't
even begin to imagine seeing all of you
in one place
I must have met at least a thousand
people while I was at comic-con and that
was for four days straight non-stop
meeting someone every single moment and
it was worth it guys it was absolutely
worth it you guys have been the most
amazing thing that has ever graced my
life and I know this is serious and I
look silly because I got a mustache
around my neck I'm neck moustache
bearding I don't know what I'm doing but
evilly just thank you guys so much for
everything and for continuing to support
me I can't thank you enough so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye